I think people gravitate to podcasts
because you you are unfiltered ya know
like I did on mine last well you got
talked about an argument I have
backstage with my opener really and it
was a legit I was throwing food at him
I'm so pissed because he yelled at me
wasn't about the food it was like would
you throw in him I got him two fried
rice and egg rolls oh man he was Asian
Oh Cambodian wait let me see what
happened and Cambodian let's be honest
dude it's asian bro but it's also a
little something else okay there being a
while even Asian people are like not
going out there you know it is ways and
roads a past Asia bro you're out there
dude well here's what happened because I
want to hear about this man because
people often say that you're hard to
deal with so I want to hear what we
talked about that I'm talking I was
talking your guys before I got on here I
got I got dude I go you know the
Internet's notorious for anybody saying
good about to get on your [ __ ] so they
see something bad I get DMS and Twitter
tags and everything and the the Bryan
Callen Brendan Schaub when they when I
all my wife got profile on Delta and
they brought it up and they go and Bryan
goes yeah I heard that guys hard to deal
with so I watched it it really was Bryan
even said he goes I don't know why I
said that I shouldn't they call you the
dude they call you the pink Chris Tucker
that's what I hear alone I'm like the
only one like he was the only black guy
with a John Deere deal I mean I'm the
only black guy the barbers I don't know
why I got a barber shop where my
pictures on the haircut yeah my guy you
want that Gary old right there on the
poster
don't let guys of me know uh let me see
what happened in Dallas
oh not hard to deal with but it's not
about the food that I threw it was that
yelled at me is what made me throw the
food because I before I went onstage you
know comedy club food isn't the best
right I'm over 40 and trying to be good
so I literally just told him I said go
anywhere just get some brown rice and
teriyaki chicken that's anywhere right
so they they they couldn't find the
place that they said they're gonna order
from they couldn't get it so I get off
stage so you know
you're hot you got three shows at night
you just want to eat you're like okay
get your palates ready for some and they
ordered Thai food and I was like I don't
you guys know me I don't like Thai food
so automatic I'm like why would you
order Thai food ya have anything you
could got me a salad right so then I
open it the vegetables look taller I
just look bad oh look like now I was
like so now I'm not not happy the only
looked good and you know Asian food
comes in two big containers was this big
container noodles and veggies and
chicken I go that looks good so I take
the fork and and out the county club
brought us plates I take the fork and
I'm taking some noodles and put on a
plate and I was gonna take some other
stuff too and just make a plate of
little samples everything so of a
container my opener comes in say goes
a toes are mine those are mine those are
my said okay I was like I'm just gonna
take a little bit is that okay he was I
oh yeah it's fine okay I take noodles
and then he takes it and it's a big
container and he puts his fork and it
immediately starts eating it so we still
got two other people in the green room
that's got to eat and I looked at my
said say you know you've been selfish
right like you should I'm thinking in my
brains you two offered something to the
other people in the room right and he
goes huh I got you know you've been
selfish right and he just went from zero
to ten because I'm not bad shellfish and
there was when he yelled at me I went
what it was I had a movie and I just
grabbed the nearest this container fried
rice I go get off he's leaving the room
I'm throwing one egg rolled a time ago
get the [ __ ] yeah he gets out
it's like the Laotian Olympics it goes
back in and he yells again he said I was
just trying to write and that there's
one more egg run I said get the [ __ ] out
he gets out right so then I calm down I
go oh yeah probably overacted right
right my Romans are Brad he explains
that he just broke it down he goes man
he's got a real live voice man I just
think I think he was hot he was hungry
and the food wasn't there that you
wanted and in says mine those were his
noodles yeah so you was eating his
noodle
I go I go yeah you probably right
pro-reactive somebody just yelled at me
man
actually I could have a discussion about
it it was him yelling that set me off
and then we're laughing about an hour
later but I talked about it on my
podcast right last week I'm telling
people start at no point that I was
right or wrong but just telling a story
but some people were like uh you know he
was wrong Gary or some people was like
I'm looking at you did for you like a
diva those were his noodles the funny
part is that's the part is the word
noodles makes it fun yeah we got a
argument over some noodles Brian Cowen
and Brendan Schaub so that's why he was
upset no but here's a funny [ __ ] about
the whole thing
I didn't throw my plate of food I had
already made my say had his noodles in
his hand one person he indeed was Brad
yeah that Roman who had nothing to do
with the Arts you mean he goes here you
just broke it down here's my thing you
thought oh yeah that is the word it is a
word so cuz sometimes you'll have a long
day of traveling you don't have a chance
to eat anything you'll get up early then
layover is really fast it'll be 30
minutes you have to get to your gate and
so then next thing you know you've had a
coffee and a muffin or something or and
a banana you finally get to the place
you you know you maybe have a snack or
something where you go on stage and then
you have to do the first show you get
off you want to eat that's your time to
finally get something to eat right and
your palates ready for something yeah
and that's not like an extravagant dish
like no brown rice interrogate chickens
you should be able to get that yeah you
should be able to get it man seven eight
in the and especially if he's Cambodian
dude you can't come up with a little
teriyaki chicken pop-up [ __ ]
Yuda Cambodian or somebody if I asked
you for [ __ ] doughnuts or something
you know and you don't know how to come
up with a coupler I asked you for you
know a couple of Cornish game hens or
something it's like asking me you know
where can I get some quiche yeah you
know tuna casserole I can make you that